in our morning rounds unleashing a new
weapon in the fight against cancer an
FDA panel is meting this morning to
decide whether to recommend the first
government approved gene therapy car T
Cell treatment uses the body's own
immune system to attack cancer it has
shown impressive results in clinical
trials against blood cancers like
Leukemia and Lymphoma our Dr David agus
leads the USC Westside Cancer Center he
is in Los Angeles uh Dr agus good
morning why would this be so significant
good morning Jeff and happy birthday
this is the first living drug it's a
pretty amazing new treatment where they
take the white cells out of a child with
cancer they send them to New Jersey and
they put in a gene to reprogram these
cells to attack the cancer they're sent
back to where the child is and Infused
and about 80% of these children go into
remission it was first tried 12 5 years
ago in a six-year-old named Emily and
she's still cancer-free to today so I
know it combats blood cancer but how are
the healthy cells
spared so in this case the that the
child has failed all standard treatments
for leukemia so they're literally at
death's door and so in this case there's
no other treatments and they knock down
her own healthy tea cells and then put
them back these new tea cells that
Target the cancer they also Target some
of the normal cells in the body and one
of the issues that's going to happen in
the panel meeting today is the f is
going to say what's the long-term
ramifications we only have the 5 years
since Emily started treatment we don't
have any further data so this is going
to be a whole new area of treatment but
because the benefits so outweigh the
harms at least initially it's probably
going to get FDA approval yeah what are
some of the the harms David and what
about the cost well they're both two
great questions so the harms are real is
that when you put in all these te- cells
that are turned on the patients many
times go into a significant distress
syndrome and can affect the brain and
other parts of the body nobody has died
from the treatment and remember this
cancer is definitely lethal within weeks
to months so the side effects are real
the cost the analysts are estimating
that it'll cost3 to
$600,000 for one treatment wow so this
is a one-time treatment that can put the
cancer into remission but staggering
costs you know recurrent lemia or
leukemia that is not responding to
treatment is rare in children about 90%
of kids are cured with conventional
chemotherapy but in these other children
this is a lifesaver well it's great to
see medicine continuing to advance and
and save people's lives Dr David AOS
thank you as always for joining us thank
you